this video is made possible by Nord VPNs
stop protecting your internet experience
today at Nord VPN comm forward slash
visual politic use code visual politic
to get 84% soft to great gifts for
months of Nord VPN and noir locker for
free and let's get into the video
[Applause]
[Music]
here's a question for you who calculates
a country's GDP I mean where do they get
the data to measure how a country's
economy is doing how do they get it what
do we really mean when we say that
China's GDP is growing at a rate of say
7%
[Music]
I'm sure you've probably already came up
with the answer GDP is measured with
statistics and surveys but well your
Commission's these reports well of
course that's the government of each
country and well who governs China that
would be the Chinese Communist Party and
here comes the real question what if
they were fudging their numbers at the
end of the day we know Beijing spends a
lot of money on propaganda at the end of
the day they need their citizens do you
believe that they live in the best of
countries and that the Xi Jingping
government couldn't be doing any better
so why not use the propaganda machine on
their macro economic figures - what if
we've been crunching the wrong numbers
this whole time
[Music]
well now hear me out nobody can deny
China's growth you've just need to see a
photo of Shenzhen 20 years ago and
compare it to the city how it is now to
see what's going on but I mean there's
not only that the best proof that China
is actually growing like crazy is the
fact that many Western businesses are
starting to sell on the Chinese mainland
a company like Lego is not an NGO and
they wouldn't consider this market if it
didn't have more and more consumers
every year so yes China is growing fast
but the question is well how fast his
where we get into the wonderful world of
nuance and believe me it won't be the
first time that this country has lied
about its figures in fact it is much
more common than you would expect
[Music]
satellite images reveal which countries
cheat on their economic statistics as
you can imagine authoritarian
governments are much more likely to lie
at the end of the day these countries
have no legal opposition no
investigative media and no watchdogs to
do independent research this was our
initial hypothesis para visual politic
we thought it made sense that China was
lying so we started doing some research
shion's
well voila we stumbled across this
China exaggerated GDP by two percentage
points for at least nine years new study
says yes in the business that's what we
call being bang on because this study it
was published in the spring of 2019 just
a few months before we did this video so
we read the study carefully we compared
it with other similar studies and we
came up with the video that you're
watching right now so today's question
is is China lying about its GDP and if
this is the case why and of course the
most important question of all what is
the real definition of GDP while today
we're going to answer all of these
questions but before we do let's take a
look at the history of GDP measures GDP
the gross domestic product is a concept
created by Russian American economist
Simon Kuznets in 1932 after World War
two it was used as a base for
calculating money transfers for the
Marshall Plan this is how it became the
standard measure but well what does it
actually measure well we're gonna tell
you right now in fact Eric is going to
tell you GDP is the sum of the final
goods produced in a country or region
during a period of time typically a year
this means that beyond wealth it
measures actual economic productivity
[Music]
so for example if you have oil fields
but you don't exploit them that doesn't
count towards GDP similarly if you have
a factory but it stops production for a
year the factory is not contributing to
GDP either but if that factory produces
one car then the market price for that
car we'd be considered part of the GDP
the gross domestic product for that year
so in other words more than money and
assets the GDP indicates the health of
an economy it doesn't care about what
you have but instead about what you can
produce and yes we're always talking
about final goods so for example let's
say that you have a restaurant and we're
making a salad we use a lettuce and
tomato and an onion each of those
ingredients costs $1 and we sell the
salad for $5 only those five dollars are
taken into account for GDP because the
salad is the final product that
consumers are going to buy another very
important thing we need to know about
GDP is that it only takes into account
new products this is why when you buy a
pre-owned house the transaction doesn't
count but if you build a brand new
dwelling and you sell it then the market
price for that will be taken into
account all of that said is GDP really
the ultimate figure for economics well
of course not if you want to analyze a
country's economic wealth you need to
consider many other figures too but so
far it really is one of the best tools
that we have
[Music]
so again we must ask where does the data
come from do they go to all of the
companies and all of the families and
ask them well you know what did you
produce now obviously that doesn't
happen they take samples in most
countries there are laws that force
companies to disclose their numbers to
the Statistics Department with those
figures they'd then do estimations then
other international organisations take
the same numbers and do their own
estimations as well for example the CIA
has a certain fact book the World Bank
or the International Monetary Fund has
something similar to that as well
[Music]
bands well you might be wondering well
why do people need so many ways of
measuring the same thing
well that's because throughout history
we've had lots of cases where different
governments were cheating and this
includes several democracies like Greece
and Argentina but hold on a minute
because there are many other ways to
make sure that GDP is accurately
measured we can compare the import and
export figures or tax collection also
some years ago satellite pictures
started to be used it turns out this can
be a very accurate system for measuring
a country's growth and one thing is
absolutely certain pictures like these
ones are extremely revealing
but okay this is all theory now let's
get into the facts what exactly is going
on in China are they lying or are their
figures accurate well let's take a look
the ideal political system imagine a
country where only the best educated
citizens can get into politics a
political system with no voting and
democracy but where instead of rewarding
empty promises made by politicians they
reward talent and results I'm sure many
of you wouldn't mind living in a place
like this right well that country's got
a name and that name would be the
Democratic People's Republic of China
this is the so called cadre system in
China politics is just another
professional career since they have no
elections the only way you can start is
from the very bottom then you can simply
work your way up the ladder in this
regard the system is very similar to
working for the big four you start as an
analyst and you climb up until you
become a partner in facts this political
system was created by Deng Xiaoping's
the architect of modern day China yes
here in the West we know him as the man
who opens up China's economy but there
he is also regarded as the man who
brought meritocracy to China prior to
him during the times of Mao Zedong
Chinese politicians were promoted based
on their compliments to the leader and
their praise of communism as a religion
nevertheless things changed in the 1980s
politicians started being judged based
on their ability to meet goals
furthermore in 1978 only 26% of Chinese
leaders had studied at University in
1990 that figure jumped to more than 90
percent but without a doubt the turning
point in this story is 1998 that was
when the Chinese Communist Party changed
the law that regulated the evaluation
system after that China would never be
the same again since then leaders have
been judged based on comparative
performance indicators for example if
the governor of a province goes to the
central committee with much worse
results than his neighbors he's going to
have problems
[Music]
now the goals are somewhat realistic but
the punishment is real if you don't meet
them in 2005 the mayor of the town where
the singing mine is was demoted why well
he didn't do everything he could to
avoid an accident so said the committee
what's more as there are many
anti-corruption investigations
if these investigations catch one of the
leaders doing something fishy sometimes
those leaders pay with their own lives
so I know other than the whole execution
thing Chinese communism doesn't sound so
bad right well this hold on a minute
because as we always say here on visual
politic the devil is in the details
[Music]
shooting at solitaire I'm going to ask
you again who compiles the numbers in
order to calculate China's GDP
you know I'm thinking well Beijing right
well actually no in such a huge country
statistics have to be done by local
governments that of course the local
leaders they cannot present worse
figures than what the Chinese committee
expects from them so what do they do I'm
sure you already guessed it they just
tell them what they want to hear this is
such a well-known fact that even Beijing
is aware of it
now you might be wondering well hang on
Simon but how do you know what Beijing
knows or doesn't know well because if we
add up all the local GDP s we get a
different number than the official one
that's provided by China's government
that's right
year after year Beijing has been
collecting their local estimations in
other words in China leaders pretend to
tell the truth and the Central Committee
pretends they believe it everyone lies
and everyone pretends to be happy just
look at this chart we can see a bit of a
pattern here up until 2006 local GDP was
lower than the official one after that
year it is the other way round this
could be an unintended consequence of
this meritocracy policy that was coming
into effect at that time now the local
leaders they're expected to do as well
as possible to get promoted and so they
inflate their figures but there is still
one more question how does Beijing know
the degree to which they have to adjust
those figures and the truth is we don't
have any idea what we do know is how the
guys from the American think tank the
Brookings Institute did it for example
one of the ways they did it was by
comparing those official numbers with
tax collection it is hot add sheet on
tax collection because this is not an
estimation but actual money that's
coming into the government's pocket and
we can always track that so where each
of the money streams comes from
businesses from the eighty this is from
the special tax on a particular industry
and so on after that we can see if both
numbers match if China says their
industrial output has grown by 10% then
the tax collection for industries should
grow accordingly and of course the tax
figures don't show that on this chart
you can see by industry the deviation
between tax collections and official
data
[Music]
if you look closely you will realize
that the deviation between both numbers
is completely random so it is easy to
believe that China might be playing with
their own numbers out of sheer
convenience and now let's hear the final
conclusion of this study this is going
to blow your mind
[Music]
our best estimate is that the true
growth rate of GDP is probably
overstated by almost two percentage
points from 2008 to 2016 2% year after
yep if this was proved mean that China's
GDP is 10% lower than what we've been
led to believe again this does not mean
that China hasn't grown during this time
at all but chances are this growth is
slower and we always thought and this
opens up the door to many other
investigations if they've been lying
about these figures what about the
others in fact this is not the first
time that we found something dodgy in
this country's finances in 2008 many
Chinese companies committed fraud when
they wanted to enter the American stock
market we're talking about non-existent
factories fake accounting books an
inflated numbers it took a team of
researchers working like something out
of a spy movie to unmask those scams in
fact you can find out more about their
work and the documentary called the
China hustle not a sponsor or anything
just a recommendation if you're
interested I will leave a link in the
description below so well now any of you
the question do you think China really
has been cheating on their accounting
because they have other frauds that we
don't yet know about and what
consequences will all of this have on
the world's economy well please leave
your answer in the comment section below
just before we end today though this
video was made possible by nord VPN if
you're buying things online and using a
public Wi-Fi spot that coffee shops
airports etc you really must be using a
VPN and that's where Nod VPN comes in I
know it's tempting not to bother and
just sort of hope for the best but
really these stories you read online
about people having their data stolen it
does happen and you don't want to make
it easy for people to do that whenever
I'm browsing public Wi-Fi I just keep
noord VPN on all the time so I don't
have to worry about anyone stealing my
data but it's not just about security
you can also use it to change the
country that you appear to be in so you
can get content that might normally only
be available in specific geographic
locations
nor VPN is super fast so watching a
video is a breeze there's no lag
whatsoever if you have a used VPNs and
thought they were slow well no more with
Nord VPN and you can use it on all of
your devices very easily Android Chrome
Windows Linux and on six different
devices with one account they might have
heard about the Nord breach in the news
recently but it's important to point out
that no user information was exposed in
this breach because Nord VPN doesn't
keep any logs on its servers because it
doesn't keep any logs at all it's based
out of Panama so it doesn't have to
however Nord VPN are still moving to a
100% owned server model unlike most
other VPNs they are also improving other
aspects of their security start
protecting your Internet experience
today at Nord VPN comm forward slash
visual politic use that code visual
politic to get 84 percent off those two
free gifts for months of Nord VPN and
Nord Locker for free and thank you for
watching